new studies suggest older adults are
more lonely than they used to be the
American Psychological Association found
on average that reported loneliness
begins to increase after the age of 75
but lonely loneliness is an issue in
fact for all generations a separate
study from 2018 found that 46% of all
adults in the u.s. sometimes or always
feel lonely and 43% feel isolated from
others dr. su varma is a psychiatrist
and she consults on depression anxiety
disorders and work-life balance issues
and she joins us now this is a major
major issue and there's a lot of
theories out there you know there's a
comedian named Gary Gulman who does this
bit about shopping at Trader Joe's and
he talks about the point of connection
when the when he's got his bag of
groceries and the clerk holds the the
credit-card receipt so he can sign it as
a little teamwork act and how that's
like a moment of connection yeah I think
about that because we shop online now is
that what's going on here yes and you
know I think there was an interesting
article in the Atlantic about how the
land line was a point of connection in
the home and the family right so these
micro conversations let's never minimize
the importance of it and I think what's
happening and when we look at that study
from 2018 it's the extremes of Ages
we're talking about 18 to 22 year olds
the generation Z that feels lonely
because what they're missing is the in
person in real life connections right so
even though we're more connected on
social media I think of it as empty
calories where if you can't take it
offline because when we look at
relationships we need to have shared
experiences right so when you're having
going through hardship you're going
through crisis whether it's a bonding
experience through boarding school boot
camp graduate school parenting whatever
it is if you're not having in real life
meaningful exchanges where you're
vulnerable with somebody where you're
forming a deep connection you're really
missing out on opportunities one
government agency is calling this an
epidemic I mean what are the warning
signs for someone who is facing this
yeah so you know first of all it's
really important to separate social
isolation from loneliness loneliness is
a subjective quality and it has to do
with whether you're with people or
without their people who are in
marriages where they're feeling
conflicted they're not getting their
needs met and they feel lonely so just
because you're surrounded by other
people don't assume that the other
person is not lonely so ask them
questions like do you feel like other
people are
with you do you feel like other people
don't understand you do you have
difficulty forming meaningful
relationships because they're people who
are very social and chatty and
party-like and outgoing and you're like
they cannot be lonely but they are
because they're not in establishing deep
and meaningful connections trust what's
the borderline sooo between loneliness
and depression and it's hard because
they often go hand-in-hand loneliness
increases the risk for depression and
people who are depressed may perceive
themselves to be lonely but they may not
necessarily be it's a perception but in
depression you see low energy low mood
low concentration and inability to get
out of bed to want to do things or you
might be high functioning and and still
be feeling depressed but that there's a
depressed mood a loneliness may feel
maybe a state a feeling that comes and
goes but depression is something that
stays over a period of two weeks or more
and affects your functioning lonely
people can still function that's the
difference I understand why this might
be affecting young people there online
all the time and I engage with each
other face-to-face but why older
Americans yes so what's very interesting
to me is look at the people who are
protected the most right we're talking
about Generation sort of baby boomers 50
to 75 they might be retired but they're
actively engaged in their communities
right they still have health more or
less and they're involved in retirement
they might be more busy than they are
when they were working but the extremes
of age beyond the age of 75 when you're
starting to lose your health and your
independence and sense of agency and
mastery which is so important that
people are dying yes and your friends
and your family very often is scattered
yes yes and you might be somebody
sending you to like a nursing home or to
community where you don't know anybody
else and then you're dependent on other
people I feel like maintaining your
independence and mobility is so
important physical mobility how do you
combat this so look at the three things
that contribute to loneliness one is the
sense of self when we think of
loneliness we only think of are you
missing interpersonal relationships but
nobody's talking about how do you feel
about yourself if you don't feel good
about yourself you're gonna feel as if I
have nothing to offer other people and
social anxiety really causes loneliness
the second piece of it is engaging with
other people meaningfully and the last
part of it is something higher outside
of yourself what can we learn from
people who aren't lonely who are those
people who just seem to have it all yes
they are not self-absorbed that's the
biggest thing right ah not self-absorbed
the people that are self-absorbed and I
don't mean this in a bad way but
depression causes an
turn right so part of this is saying
what can I do even if you're depressed
even if you're feeling lonely how can I
give back to somebody else can you get
involved in a community are you
volunteering what I love to do is pair
teenagers or young people in the in the
generations either lonely with the
oldest group right both people are
lonely but both have so much to add when
you put teens and sort of grandparents
together everybody benefits there's one
fact what they're really underscores the
stakes here loneliness is compared to
smoking 15 cigarettes a day really
affects your physical health get out
there he met dr. sue Varma thank you so
much for being with us